Donald Trump's attorney general Jeff
Sessions has declared that the arrest of
WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange is now
a quote priority CNN reported that the
US Justice Department has been preparing
charges against Julian Assange who's
probably most well known for well I
would say most well known for
facilitating the publishing of all of
those classified documents in 2010 that
were leaked by Chelsea Manning more
recently for the dnc hacking leaks
during the 2016 election and Assange has
been living at the Ecuadorian Embassy in
London since 2012 evading charges
related to both WikiLeaks and sexual
assault from different parties
Republicans have been endlessly
hypocritical about WikiLeaks they
condemned the 2010 US military leaks but
then they praised WikiLeaks during the
2016 DNC leaks including Donald Trump's
praise of that Trump actually told CNN
back in 2010 talking about WikiLeaks and
Chelsea Manning quote I think it's
disgraceful I think there should be like
death penalty or something but then last
year Trump said he loves WikiLeaks
probably because they helped him in the
2016 election but the Justice Department
seems to have a sort of different
opinion about Assange at the moment and
as soon as I saw this I thought see yet
another attempt to appear neutral about
something related to Russia Jeff
Sessions the Attorney General told the
press conference in El Paso on Thursday
quote we are going to step up our effort
and already are Stefan stepping up our
efforts on all leaks this is a matter
that's gone beyond anything I'm aware of
we have professionals that have been in
the security business of the United
States for many years that are shocked
by the number of leaks and some of them
are quite serious we also have a quote
from last week from CIA director Mike
Pompeo who said in a speech it's time to
call out WikiLeaks for what it really is
a non-state hostile intelligence service
often abetted by state actors like
Russia Julian Assange has no First
Amendment freedoms he's sitting in an
embassy in London he's not a US citizen
now Julian Assange his lawyer has said
nobody's been in touch with us from the
Justice Department that doesn't mean
they're not working on charges Ecuador
says it doesn't plan to extradite
Assange any time soon the real important
core issue here is that typically we see
the leaker published Chelsea Manning
obtained these documents and gave them
to WikiLeaks WikiLeaks published the
documents the pot the punishment of the
publisher is sort of a gray area with
WikiLeaks but it's also sort of a red
line when it comes to the prosecution of
publishers we could say well listen
maybe WikiLeaks is not exactly like the
New York Times in terms of the First
Amendment protections that they have
with regard to publishing documents like
this I don't know I mean you could you
could differ on that Pat but still
believe that they did not steal or
violate protocol to obtain the documents
WikiLeaks received documents and thus
prosecuting WikiLeaks could signal some
pretty important First Amendment
concerns when it comes to the the
prosecution of media outlets
I don't think WikiLeaks is illegitimate
because it published information that it
got from someone that did something
wrong that really isn't the main concern
newspapers like the New York Times and
Washington Post do it all the time
WikiLeaks also isn't illegitimate
because the person who gave them the
information might have been doing it for
reasons you don't like right you could
disagree with why Chelsea Manning gave
these documents to Wikileaks
that doesn't mean WikiLeaks did anything
illegal and I think WikiLeaks is
actually legitimate because they will
publish things that could be detrimental
to both sides of the equation and they
got a lot of backlash because they
release things that specifically harmed
Hillary Clinton in this past election
cycle but that just could be because
that's what they had I am mixed about
that I am mixed about that only by
agreeing in principle at the same time
you know we could say they need to vet
the information properly and the release
of a lot of those Podesta leaks they
didn't really tell us much and they
actually did harm people for example
James ala fantasize a guy's name is the
guy who ran comet ping-pong who suffered
at the
hands of conspiracy theorists because of
all the pizza gate stuff right so I
think that WikiLeaks does have a duty to
vet newsworthiness to some degree don't
you think it's not as if Pizza Gate was
outright mentioned if you look at the
text of the Podesta things they just
claimed there were code words yeah right
I mean it was used to further this
entire pizza gate conspiracy theory so
this is going to be a really important
story to keep an eye on because yeah
what I'm saying is that we don't know if
Donald they had anything on Donald Trump
specifically and chose not to release it
fair enough fair enough no I completely
agree with you as far as that goes
if indeed we see the attempt to
prosecute Julian Assange for what he did
this is going to be a red line when it
comes to the war on whistleblowers and
leakers etc because once you go beyond
just individuals who stole classified
information
you could make the judgement that okay
it's worth it for me to leak these
classified documents secret documents
that are I'm sort of bound not to make
public and I'm willing to suffer the
consequences of that Chelsea Manning
could make that call any leaker or
whistleblower could make that call but
to go to the next step and say news
outlets or online publishers like
WikiLeaks who receive information that
they believe to be newsworthy that they
had no part in illegally obtaining they
could be prosecuted to me Pat that's
crossing a pretty significant red line
here and I would be concerned going
forward about how this will influence
media outlets because imagine that there
is prosecution of someone like Julian
Assange if you're then the Washington
Post and you get from somewhat the next
Chelsea Manning similar documents now
you might say well I used to think that
I would be okay publishing this because
I didn't obtain the documents illegally
I am just publishing them you're gonna
think twice and it is going to
absolutely suppress what we are going to
learn about what our government is doing
and you can connect that to the Trump
Russia dossier where BuzzFeed and CNN
reported on that directly yeah are you
going to turn around and punish them too
and not just the people who put together
the dossier and released it to the
public probably yeah you probably are if
this sort of line of reasoning continues
so I'm very very concerned about this
and we'll see what happens
send me your thoughts about this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show the david
pakman show has a new sponsor tag a DAB
offers a range of affordable flexible
hosting packages including dedicated
virtual private server and cloud server
options as well as custom server
solutions and UK colocation services
tailored to your business or project
they are very proud of their team of
expert hosting specialists who know
their stuff they make up their friendly
support team they give customers full
access to what they know and to their
services and 70% of their business comes
from repeat orders and recommendations
from existing customers which is really
a testament to the support that they are
giving their customers taga dab
currently has an average Trustpilot
review rating of excellent at nine point
seven out of ten with more and more
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to cloud hosting
taga dab is offering a ten-pound credit
to all new customers signing up to give
you a chance to try the service
regardless of where in the world you are
there in the UK you can be anywhere to
take advantage of the offer and support
the David Pakman show go to signup
tag a DAB comm slash TDPS that's signup
dot ta ga da b.com slash TDP s